[Applause]
so I guys when is Ross I've got the
github link to I'm going to talk about
here so we just could iron quickly if
you want to look at it well I'm doing
his talk so github.com 89 to 90 mentor
ml you may remember me from such things
as five bucks two years ago and recently
with Rob we made papers with codes it's
like ml per site we can see that latest
trending papers so three problems with
deep learning software or repos whatever
you wanna call them one Mac of
compatibility so we often see and get up
repos there's a new model that's like a
Yolo mode or maybe it's like
relativistic gang you go in there and
everything's like kind of lump together
it's not very composed but everything is
tightly coupled so you have your model
architecture as your data it's quite
actually hard to extract what you want
and reuse it for something so if it's
like a new paper it's like a new I know
lost functional again or something you
have no idea where is it's like a 1000
line piece of code and it's very very
tightly coupled together
point number two moving artifacts
between local GPU instances s3 so
sometimes you do training locally
sometimes you want to do it in a GPU
instance sometimes you might have your
data stored in s3 so there's a lot of
different artifacts are moving about
it's quite hard to keep track of things
and listening to number three as well so
you want to know what dates if versions
they used model these are the three
general problems so I'm gonna argue that
actually this is all these three things
I may seem I mean it's somewhat
connected but I guess on the surface
they also seem disconnected but I mean I
- they come from the state of machine
learning software right now it's like in
a very nascent State and it's kind of
like where software used to be so if
you've read this classic here from the
90s
it has a lot a similar problem was
solved in web apps and other software
it's got like a MVC pattern so if you
think about Django what they're doing
there is that they have a design pattern
for doing a web app where you keep your
models in one place views at one another
place and you have a controller that can
announce it and then the idea who is
that philosophically it's like loosely
coupled it means you can for example
change of you for the same model so if
you could be like say like a page and
it's gonna reference the same underlying
data structure model we can easily swap
out different components
so it got me thinking like could we do
something similar for machine learning
software so instead of how you know
these massive big ugly scripts you can
easily write just take different
components like data remodels and swap
them out so if I have like a new game
for example I shouldn't have to
understand the specific way they've done
a data processing thing I should be able
to take out the data they use and put it
in or take out the evaluation metric of
their use and put it in now some of this
is already solved I guess we like API
layers like Kira's and stuff but I just
wanted to see if I could own a more
general level so this is the library I'm
gonna release this week it's called
mantra nice fancy logo and in goats on
github repo I just this guy so central
mantra is a bit like I guess I had its
kind of phrase it was a bit like Jango
Fett ml in the census imposing this kind
of structure on the backend where you
have what was one place data one in one
place and then what kind of neatly
packaged up so I'm just going to show a
brief example you can see on the readme
know more about the motivation but
essentially if I just get rid of this
guy I have a folder structure and it's a
bit Jenga risk so you might not be able
to see that I use this instead I used a
GUI so I have different things different
folders model data tasks and so on and
this represents a unlined project
obviously that's quite ugly even in the
GUI and move on to whatever so I can
bring up a UI just to see the state my
project which I'm going to do now and my
ports Audion use of goods right and I
can see that online folder structure now
I have a visual representation so here I
have some models and have some data sets
and what I want to show is actually what
you see here you'd have to do a little
work to get it into this kind of nice
visual framework so if I go into let's
see I have here at CNN example and this
is just the folder as you can see some
that folder called deep sea and then my
code here you know probably to quote see
it essentially it's just a standard
Kiros model but I've put it into a
specific folder through that field
framework I know I'm doing is adding
some little callbacks here so it's kind
of curious esque steel and that's going
to get you into this framework which now
going to show you what kind of
it can do so that's a model script and I
also have some datasets here so I have
some image data sets I have some Premier
League later so if I just take an
example what you can do for the command
line here's one I did earlier so you can
do it programmatically as well free
notebook so I can just do easy training
for the command line so here I'm just
gonna train a gistic regression model
and some data I've got a task here which
is lovely evaluation metrics I'm using
binary cross enter free I'm gonna
specify the target and features and hope
this works to some training my local
fortunately logistic regression so I'd
have to [ __ ] around GPUs my local but
there you go
while it's training you can use the UI
and see what's going on so I'm goes
their trials page here as in back out I
can see I'm a trainee model here you
down to [ __ ] around a tense the board
it's all done for you so if I just load
this up I can see the model its training
kind accuracy and loss work supply torch
to so what's all the different
frameworks defensible think that and I'm
just gonna do it quickly another example
so if I add a new feature say feature
five and then do ten effects doesn't
take you long
yay but oh there we go yeah feature the
perils of live coding say that's five
ethics and all the trials I can see you
can see it for a nice UI and they're
grouped by the model so here I can see
some trials have done and I can compare
the different trials yay more errors
like I said it's only on this week so I
can see the high prompts here so the
target so I'm just I've just like a 1 or
0 whether the home team won so sports
dataset and see what features I've used
and basically from the code level if you
add more hyper parameters basically
comes up automatically in the UI so you
got if you are doing a deep learning
model net so you added a dropout
parameter like self dropout or so on it
automatically appears in the UI so the
fact you package in a certain way just
means you get all these like cool
benefits and I can also see if I go into
data so I did all this in premier league
data I can go to the tasks and I can
compare different models see like a
tiger like leaderboard so if I write
this date a new model I could just run
on
same task or same data and just have
like an easy way to compare different
things that's that and the final thing
is this is on the local now I think no
Morrow's blocking me from SS aging into
Amazon but his one of the cool things
you can do so if I now do a relativistic
gap I choose I've got a dataset called
Dex skateboard graphics to get on the
cloud you just simply put a cloud
argument and it does it automatically so
that well that's going to do is we move
everything to your cloud environment you
just have to configure the API keys and
sets of an environment for you does the
training returns everything to s3 in
your local it looks something like was
the last of that sexy to see it but
essentially you just put in the details
add the cloud sag and then essentially
it sets up all the cloud stuff for you
down to the only DevOps hashes the
different components sets it up an
instance does the training returns
things for you so the goal is like if
you wanted to set up like 15 GPUs and do
distributed training it would do all the
horrified stuff for you you want to do
anything to set up work it just works
whatever back in do you want and again
so for this everything's configured so I
could see it live doing training again I
can see the 10 support state so this is
a damn thing I did earlier and I can see
the loss like put in a discriminator and
generator and then everything is stored
necessary and it's returned to my local
as well so I can go and see for this
trial some can I did I can see it's a
the latest iteration septic 61 here's
some shitty skateboard deck so I
generated these a bit more training
interesting you see the middle one the
reason why it's doing nice because it's
doing it interpolation interpolation and
the taste that's actually quite binary
there's some stable big decks going up
like that something like that and the
model thinks that somehow that's a
skateboard deck if you combined it to
conserve interrelation anyway so that
that's that's the essence of it so it's
only library gonna release it this week
but if that sounds interesting
check it out and yeah very
let's welcome to feedback thank you
[Applause]